- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Mapping
As Knowing Lecture Series
of the Franke Program
in science and the humanities at Yale.
I am delighted to introduce
our speaker this evening.
So, science fiction writer
Kim Stanley Robinson,
who will be talking to us about
mapping the future of the Anthropocene.
So, first I want to...
I see Richard and Barbara Franke there
signed in to our Zoom universe.
So, I wanted to thank both
of them for their generosity
in endowing the Franke Program,
that is allowing us to post
these wonderful events.
So, thank you, Richard
and Barbara and welcome.
I also want to remind
everyone who has signed in
that we are recording this.
So, could you kindly turn off your videos
and mute your microphones for now?
And the format that we are
planning to have for this evening
is that Stan will be speaking
for about 40, 45 minutes
and we will take questions afterward.
So, kindly type in your
questions on the chat
and Ty Kamp,
Hi, Ty, hello.
She will be managing the chat.
And I also want to give
a big shout out to Ty
without whose help
we will not be able to run
this program as smoothly.
So, very grateful Ty
for your help with this.
So, without further ado,
let me introduce,
I don't quite know where to start.
So, first I have to control
my gushiness a little bit
because I am a really ardent
fan of Stan and Stan's writing.
So, Stan, as you all know,
is one of the foremost writers
of the science fiction genre.
And he began publishing novels in 1984.
And his work has been described
as humanist science fiction,
literary science fiction.
So, in a way he crosses genres,
although one could fairly comfortably say
that what he really envisions and imagines
are views of the future
but infused with an
emotional, psychological
and human touch.
So, it's not just about
robots and automation.
So, he is a very proud
defender and advocate
of the genre of science fiction.
And he actually regards,
and I think me and many
other fans around the world
concur that it's one of the most powerful
of all literary forms,
because it allows us to imagine futures,
futures that we all dream about
and futures that we sometimes
are scared of as well.
So, he was born in Illinois
but moved to California
when he was very young
and he has remained a loyal Californian.
He has often talked about...
I want to give you a bit of a feel for him
because this is one of
the things about Zoom,
because you can't see
the person in the flesh.
So, I want to give you
a little more sort of
biographical information
so that you can kind of imagine
what must be influencing
the way in which he
thinks and sees the world.
So, he grew up playing in orange groves,
stretching out for miles
and in a very suburban part of California
that over his lifetime
fundamentally transformed.
And with encroaching
urbanism and modern life
kind of entering closer and closer in
and changing sort of the
environment around him.
So, he was very sensitive to that
and I mention this because
many of you who read him
will see that this attunement to nature
and to the attunement
to how humans have been
transforming nature
is a very fundamental
theme that runs through
many of his books.
So, he actually stumbled
upon science fiction late,
relatively speaking,
while he was in college.
And then it made such a strong impression
that he knew immediately
that he was really committed
to becoming a writer
and that was the genre
that he would really pick for himself.
So, he enrolled at University
of California at San Diego
and received his BA in Literature.
And he started at that time already
he had developed the idea
of writing a trio of books
exploring three different
alternative histories
in which Southern California
had gone down different paths.
And this is the famous
"Orange County Trilogy."
Then he briefly left California
and came eastward to Boston University
and did an MA in English
and then went back to UCLA to finish PhD.
So, he finished his PhD in 1982
and a revised version of his PhD
was what was published in '84
as the novels of Philip K. Dick.
So, after publishing these few novels,
Stan moved with his wife,
who is an environmental
toxicologist and a renowned chemist,
and they moved to Switzerland
where they lived for a few years
and then he began at that
point to write full-time.
Then they came back to Washington DC.
But eventually they just
moved back to California
and he lives still in Davis
I think since 1991, right,
you've been in Davis.
And they actually live
with his wife and son
they live in Village Homes,
which is sort of a plant community
that shares many things in
common with the community
that he depicts in his
1999 old "Pacific Edge."
And so, he is actually a very
proud stay-at-home parent,
which gives them a lot of
time to write and think
and his wife who's career he has supported
works full-time as a chemist.
And many of you have likely read
his "Aurora," the "Mars Trilogy."
I don't know where to start.
And he has so many awards and recognition
that I'm not going to take any
more time from his talk today
to mention them.
So, what can I say?
I'm personally an ardent fan of Stan
and as a scientist
and as an astrophysicist,
I'm very finicky about the
sci-fi that I read and love.
I find that it's often very hard
to get that needed distance
to derive pleasure from the writing
as when as always apt to
interrogate the science
all the time.
And so, Stan's writing is one
that I have had no trouble with at all.
And his books have been singular
as while they don't always necessarily
take me where I intended to go,
I have always ended up
where I needed to be.
So, I would like to turn it over to Stan
and we really look forward to,
and thank you so much
for agreeing to speak
and we look forward to hearing you.
- Well, thank you very much
for that kind of introduction, Priya,
and thank you, Ty
and the Frankes and Yale.
It's a real pleasure,
and I hope that we also get
to do this in person someday
post vaccine
in a more mobile and social time.
I really look forward to that.
And yes,
today I'm gonna talk about
mapping the Anthropocene.
And it's an interesting assignment
kind of given me by Priya
and by this speaking series
and allowed me to think about it
in ways that I quite enjoyed.
If you talk about mapping the future
then you are necessarily
talking about cognitive mapping.
So, that's really the framework
for everything then follows.
And so, as Priya said,
I'll speak for about 40 to 45 minutes
and then hope to engage
with questions as well.
So, cognitive mapping.
This is a phrase that my
teacher Fredric Jameson,
who also taught at Yale
for a couple of years,
brings forth is it's somewhat
like weather forecasting
or a modeling exercise
or scenario building trajectory following.
You see it a lot in the sciences
and everywhere else.
And it's necessarily ideological.
And I mean that in the best sense
because I take ideology to
mean an imaginary relationship
to the real situation.
I like this definition a lot
because there is a real
situation out there
but our knowledge of
it has to be imaginary
and by which I mean selective,
partial and shaped by
our prior assumptions
so that we see some
evidence better than others
based on our axioms.
And so, maps become a kind of
an analogy for this process
and maps to our ideological.
And by analogy,
think of the Mercator projection,
where Greenland is as
large as North America
and Novaya Zemlya is
as large as Australia.
This is a distortion
that is made by some axioms
that you use to put the
globe onto a flat surface.
Now you can try to adjust for that
and this is exactly what ideological work
can be conceptualized as.
You can make adjustments
to keep the continent sized accurately
to the way that they
are in the real world.
You have to cut a globe apart
and spread out your map in a
kind of transverse directions,
kind of a giant triangle on a wall.
And this, you get a different distortion,
which is that the oceans are erased
and Antarctica doesn't
get included very well.
So, in the end,
you might even want a
globe instead of a map.
And of course, this is
another kind of map,
but it's cast onto the same shape
as the thing it's trying to represent.
And this might be an
interesting way to think of.
Can you adjust your ideology
to get a better view
of what you're looking at?
And also, if you're
mapping the Anthropocene,
you're mapping the future.
You're mapping time rather than space.
And here it gets incredibly complicated
because what unit of time is relevant?
This would be something
to talk with Priya about
in more detail
but it seems to me that I hear
that in subatomic physics,
there is indeed a minimum unit of time
that you can't go below
because I think it's the
Pauli exclusion principle
that objects can't occupy the same space.
And then the speed of
light crossing that space
gets you to something like
10 to the negative 34th of a second.
That's a pretty short minimum,
but you can't go smaller
without breaking the laws of physics.
And then at the other
end you have eternity
or maybe the age of the universe.
13.82 billion years
is the latest estimates of astrophysicists
and I love that too at
the end of the 0.82.
That's pretty precise considering
the question involves.
But in between that,
if you're trying to map the future,
what do you do?
And can you look at your
assumptions in a way that,
if for instance
going back to maps of the world,
that puts South at the top?
And I think that's a good
thing to keep in mind
that there was probably
assumptions that we're making
that we seldom interrogate or think about.
Why is North always at the top of the map
and South of the bottom?
When you reverse it,
it looks weird and wrong,
but maybe you need to do that
to realize that it's arbitrary
and sort of axiomatic.
So, let's think about the Anthropocene.
What is it?
Well, it's another cognitive mapping
and it's of splitting up time into units.
So, some unit between
the minimum and eternity.
And this is what historians
would call periodization.
And again, my teacher, Fred Jameson,
we cannot not periodize.
In other words,
you can never look at history and say,
well, it's just one uninterrupted flow
from the beginning of the
universe till right now
and you just take it one second at a time.
We don't do that.
We periodize.
And each system of periodization
reveals a theory of history
that is making the cuts.
So, you can simply do it numerically.
There's the 16th century,
the 17th century,
the 18th century, the 19th century.
Numerical, and it's simple in that regard,
but that's still periodizing
then in each century
you think something different is going on.
There's systems of power.
Imperial systems like
the Chinese dynasties.
That's how they periodized
Chinese history sometimes.
Or empire names.
The Roman empire, the
Persian empire, and so on.
There's the technological.
So, you have the paleolithic
followed by the agricultural revolution,
the industrial revolution,
steam era, coal era,
the electronic era,
the nuclear era,
the digital era.
These are all technological
periodizations.
And then you have the cultural.
So, middle ages,
the Renaissance,
the enlightenment,
the modern period,
the postmodern period,
which we were in until this
word Anthropocene got invented,
but nobody was particularly happy
because what comes after post modernism?
You would have to have post postmodernism.
And it was clearly a provisional name,
but something was changing in modernism
that hadn't yet been properly theorized.
So it was a tag name that
started in the mid '80s,
again with Jameson's strong support.
And now I think has been superseded
by the name Anthropocene
but we'll talk about that.
And then lastly,
there's the geological.
Okay, the fossil record
gives us a way of interpreting
the past of the earth,
such that there are break
points along the way
and names that go along with them.
And this is really complicated.
There is actually a
stratigraphy committee,
the American Geophysical Union
and geologists in general have
parsed the past very finely
in different formats of changes.
But let's just think about the Triassic,
the Jurassic, the Cretaceous
and then after the Cretaceous,
which ended 65 million years ago,
which with what we now consider
to probably be a meteor
impact at the KT boundary.
Subsequent post Cretaceous,
also divided into periods,
that eventually ended up in the Holocene,
which was where we've been
since the end of the last ice
age about 11,000 years ago.
Okay, and all of that,
the Anthropocene is a word invented
by a Eugene steamer in the 1980s.
And it was picked up by
scientist Paul Crewdson
in 2000 or 2002.
He was using this
periodization politically,
and this is so often the case,
in order to emphasize the
danger of human impacts
on earth's biosystem.
He was trying to make the point
that humanity had become the largest force
in the critical zone
from the top of the atmosphere
to the bottom of the bed,
to bedrock,
the live stone, you might say.
The biosphere itself.
That humans were the largest force
in transforming that zone quickly
and mostly in a bad way
and that was why you would
call it the Anthropocene.
And this definition is
therefore a combination
of the geological kind of cut,
the human various cuts
that sometimes get called big history
so that you include the planet,
but also the other ones culturally
and all other periodization schemes
have collided in this
term, the Anthropocene
to give it a particular
power and suggestiveness
to our reckoning of where
we are now in history.
Now, I wanna note on the side
that the Anthropocene,
as such, as a definition,
is a kind of a science fiction story.
If you imagine that 25
million years in the future,
aliens come to earth,
alien geologists or scientists
or some post-human version of us
come back to earth or whatever
and they look at it
and they study its geological record,
they will be able to see a change point
like the KT boundary
that marks where humans began
to intervene so intensively
that it could be seen
25 million years later
in the geological record
of just the rocks.
Well, that's a provocation.
Immediately, people ask
well, what marker are you talking about?
I think this question
is not so interesting
because if you add up all the markers,
it will be undeniably the case.
It could be the rapid shift in CO2 levels,
although the aliens might say,
"Well, something happened naturally."
It could be the sudden appearance
of radioactive elements
in the surface from our atomic explosions.
It could be a layer of
plastics and micro plastics,
although will those last 25 million years?
Et cetera, et cetera.
The Anthropocene as where it started
has become a kind of minor
academic argument or game
that people play
to make various points
about the impacts of humans.
When Europeans arrived in the new world,
their diseases and their genocide
killed off the local populations
to the point that the areas of land
that had been being kept clear
by new world native American populations
reforested so quickly
that there was a drop in the
CO2 level in the atmosphere
at that time, et cetera.
Let's say that probably
the atomic explosions
will serve like the iridium
layer at the KT boundary.
That it's weird and there
was no other good explanation
so that the Anthropocene is probably real.
Now, another game in academia
immediately came into play.
Maybe it's not humanities
impact or the Anthropocene.
Maybe it's the way we've
been exploiting the earth
and other people
that has made an irrevocable mark
in the geological record.
And so, it's been called
provisionally the Capitalocene,
suggesting that it wasn't
people but capitalism
that left the big marks
in the geological record.
But now this is another
kind of science fiction
called the alternative history.
In other words,
you're implying that
if there had been a different
social organization for humans
since the 16th century,
since modernization,
that would have not left the
same kind of mark on the earth.
You could imagine a sociolo scene
or a medicino scene
or a scienco scene
or a utopiao scene
in which the geological
mark wouldn't be clear
because we had done such a good job
of matching our activities to
the biosphere's capacities.
Well, I think this is very unlikely
and alternative history is weak
precisely because you can't test it.
It's just an assertion.
And therefore it's impossible to prove.
And so, I think it's best
to stick to the Anthropocene
as the name for this.
That, I think, can be defended
as a real mark in geological history.
So, what does it imply?
Because I wanna say immediately,
and this is fundamental to
mapping the Anthropocene.
The humanities impact on the biosphere
is not necessarily the
equivalent of saying disaster,
of saying mass extinction
event and total disruption.
In other words,
there could be a good Anthropocene.
The Anthropocene could be a good one
or it could be a bad one
and that's the first part of our mapping.
The first map of the Anthropocene
looks like a sort of a perfect spread out,
a blunderbuss, you might say,
from one point with a
trajectory shooting off
in all directions from a
really horrific catastrophe
of a mass extinction event
that would hammer humanity as well.
But what I wanna say is that
this spread of possibilities right now,
which is disorienting,
and that's a good word to use
when you're talking about maps.
If the future that we're facing
could be anything from our
horrific mass extinction event
that wrecks human civilization
and leaves us in some kind
of post-apocalyptic dystopia.
And yet on the other hand,
it could also be a
progressively better adjustment
to the biospheric limits
and to technologies and to social systems
such that we get to a prosperous age.
I don't wanna say utopia.
I don't wanna say golden age.
I just wanna say it could get really good.
So, that being the case,
it's so confusing.
But what I wanna suggest
is that from this point,
if things begin to degrade
and we don't address
our problems right away,
then what you get to
you begin to slide off into bad futures
that are harder and harder to deal with.
If we deal with our problems now
and begin to improve our systems
and get a handle on our problems,
then things begin to get better and better
in ways that will be robust.
And what I wanna suggest is
it's the middle that is excluded
in a kind of an Aristotelian way.
It's as if we're walking down a peninsula
and this peninsula
is a sharp on both
directions going downhill
and the peninsula is also attenuating
and getting more and more narrow
where choices have to be made.
This is a kind of a backpacker's,
a rambler in the Sierras type image,
but I bring it up
because I wanna suggest that
the moves we make now
will be determinative
for the next three or four generations
of how desperate, if we were
to go down the bad side,
how desperate it would be for them
to crawl back over the
ridge onto the good side,
whereas right now it would
be less difficult to do it.
Now, this map of the ridge edge
dropping to bad or good
is actually topologically
exactly the reverse
of some maps I've seen of
our possibilities right now.
And these are also valuable.
So, these are all thought exercises.
I'm thinking of a paper
in the National Academy of Sciences
that has the future
as a kind of a big valley going downhill,
U-shaped Valley lichen and glacial area,
where almost all of the futures
lead to temperatures that are too high.
And then if we do a certain
number of things correctly,
you could go up and sideways
into a zone of safety.
And so, again,
it's topological or
topographical and it's imagery.
It's like a map
and it's the opposite of
the map I just suggested
and yet it probably
speaks to something real
that is maybe focused in
particular on our CO2 use.
So, it's not wrong
but these are three different
maps, right, in a row.
The blunderbuss of the future
could be anything from terrible to gray.
The ridge going downhill suggesting that
we best get it right now
in order to make things better
for following generations.
And then also the big Valley drop,
which also suggests that that side canyon
is coming up quickly.
That gets us off into a safe future.
So, now for the rest of the talk here,
I am going to ignore describing
the bad Anthropocene,
because I think it's just too obvious.
Essentially the name for it
could be the mass extinction
event that we're heading into.
And a mass extinction event
could lead to crop failures,
which would lead to food
shortages for humans.
It also could lead to
rises in temperatures
to where you get up into
the wet-bulb 35 zone,
which is that zone of heat
and humidity in combination
that would lead to human deaths
without air conditioning.
In other words,
overwhelming the human body's ability
to regulate its temperatures,
sweating doesn't work in
the high heat humidity.
The heat gets high enough.
The combination of the two
is a kind of heat index.
What bulb 35 is a fatal to human beings.
And it could be only 95
degrees in terms of heat
but if that 95 degrees is combined
with a super high humidity,
it becomes fatal.
And so, civilization would be hammered
in a bad Anthropocene.
And that would mean that
although humans probably
wouldn't go extinct
because of a certain clever
resilience that we have
and there's so many of us
that with the help of
our social organization
and technology and hanging in there,
it isn't really right
to talk about extinction
but it would certainly
be a post-traumatic time
like, oh my gosh.
In generations past,
we screwed up so badly
that we don't have any federal animals
and we're only one 10th
the population we were.
It would be a dark ages
followed by a post-traumatic
and dysfunctional human time.
It would make the dark
ages after the Roman empire
look like almost nothing, really.
It would be way, way, way, way worse.
So, let's leave that on the side.
What would a good Anthropocene look like
and how do we get there?
So, good Anthropocene.
Let's think about that.
What it would look like
I think is very simple.
First of all, in a negative
sense, no mass extinction event.
We would have dodged the
mass extinction event
and the other animals and
plants that are all endangered
would still be with us
in a viable biosphere.
Now that's a minimum,
but it's very important
because the only unfixable
thing in our biosphere
with the resilience and
robustness of life is extinction.
Don't be fooled by this
science fiction trope
of de-extinction.
It's interesting to try it
and it might even work for a
couple of targeted species.
It's a nice thought experiment
but it isn't a solution.
It won't work for the
most of the extinctions
that will happen.
So, we need to Dodge a
mass extinction event.
That's the minimum.
Then also we have to think about people.
It's our species.
We're in the Anthropocene.
What do humans do?
You would want to postulate
that there's enough food,
water, shelter, clothing,
healthcare, education, work and security,
safety, and peace for everybody.
Adequacy for everybody.
Nobody immiserated.
That would be another benchmark
of a good Anthropocene.
And you can also just call that justice.
So, a good Anthropocene
there would be justice.
And then also in balance with
the biosphere's energy flows
and with its ability to process
our wastes and our pollution.
These are two very
important flow questions
that not only humans
would be in balanced with its biosphere
but the immediate implication of that
would be that all the
rest of the living world
would also be at adequacy and okay.
So, let's just say 10 billion people
and hope that that's a maximum
and it seems quite likely actually.
And all of them with enough
and all of the rest of the
living world has enough also.
Now, can this be done?
Physically in terms of energy flows, yes.
We have the physical capability
and the technological
capability of achieving that,
which is good news, I think.
And it comes out of an assessment
of the scientific
communities investigations.
It's only possible to get to that
if that becomes humanities project.
We won't kludge to it.
We won't get there accidentally
and we won't get there
if we pursue humanities project right now,
which is the creation of profit
in the capitalist system.
That's an index
that is putting together
any number of factors
to make a number that accrues value
to a small percentage of
the world's population
in a power system.
This is what capitalism is
but the index of profit is fate
on any number of levels
and it ends up being a
kind of a Ponzi scheme
or a multi-generational Ponzi scheme.
So, this is another way to map the future.
Systematically stealing in a kleptocracy
from the generations to come
as well as the rest of the life world.
So, if we were gonna get
to a good Anthropocene,
we would have to change
the political economy
that we live in
that we now are call
neoliberal late capitalism.
The system of laws that
runs the world right now
in all of our activities
in an over determining way
and even science itself has to get funded.
This world is set up
with goals and rewards
that are destroying the biosphere
and also wrecking human lives.
This is the sad news, the bad news.
It's as obvious as heck though.
There's no reason for me to insist on it
because if it weren't true,
then why would we be in
the world that we're in?
And of course there
have been improvements.
There has been poverty reduction.
There are good things happening.
They all happen as a gift
economy on this side.
None of them have been profitable.
UN's millennial project of 2000
to lift the poorest and
most immiserated people
on the planet up into adequacy,
that's been achieved and
it wasn't even that costly
but it wasn't profitable.
And it was done on the side,
outside the rule of profit.
And that's interesting
because if we could do that on the margin,
what could we do
if it was actually the whole
point of civilizations efforts?
So, I'm gonna briefly
through some other points
in a good Anthropocene.
One of the necessary,
I mean, it wouldn't be sufficient
but it's necessary
is to decarbonize fast
and maybe even get into carbon draw-down
out of the atmosphere.
So, okay, on the technological level,
we'd have the means to create
a steady state balanced
with the biosphere but
we're not there yet.
We've invented it but
we haven't applied it.
And right now the burning of fossil fuels
is a major impact on the environment.
It'd be best to get back to
350 parts per million
of CO2 in the atmosphere
and there are various means to do that.
Well, technological and biological,
it may be could be done
but it would be a very
big, expensive project.
It would have to be the
goal of civilization
and maybe it should be.
So, here's another map for you.
We can afford to burn like 500
gigatons more of fossil fuel
into the atmosphere
before we would hit that
two degrees Celsius rise
in average global temperature.
That has been identified
as the maximum we can get
without horrific results.
500 gigatons is 500 billion tons of carbon
burned into the atmosphere.
At the rate we're going,
that's about 15 more years.
But listen to this,
about 3,500 gigatons of fossil carbon
have been identified and located
by geologists and by
scientists around the world
and this 3,500 gigatons of carbon,
about 70% of that is
owned by nation states
and about 30% by private corporations.
That 3,500 gigatons of fossil carbon,
3,000 gigatons needs to stay in the ground
and never be burned into the atmosphere
but it's already on the books
as assets for the private companies
and it's already in the national imaginary
of the countries involved
that have the most parts of this
as a national security issue.
That in other words,
many national economies
depend on sailing and
burning that fossil carbon
to support everything else
that they do for their people.
Now, every one of these nation states
have signed the Paris agreement
and has agreed to stay below two degrees.
The implications of that
create a logical contradiction
in that many countries rely on selling
and burning precisely the carbon
that they've also promised
not to sell and burn.
And I'm not just talking
about Saudi Arabia,
although they are big amongst them
but also Russia, the
United States, of course,
Canada, Australia, Venezuela,
Brazil, Mexico, South Africa.
It goes on and on.
China and India.
It goes on and on that
these fossil fuel assets
for these countries are on the books
and the politicians are
thinking to themselves,
"We'll just burn what we can get away with
"before this becomes a stranded asset.'
There will be a social forces
trying their hardest to burn
the whole 3,500 gigatons.
And because the value of those 3,000
that shouldn't be burned
if you were to make it,
completely artificial exercise,
would be approximately...
I costed it once
when the price of oil was a
little higher than it is now,
it's something like $1,600 trillion
and people are gonna want that money.
So, here's an interesting map.
There should be a world map
that shows where all
this fossil carbon is.
You could easily coal, oil, natural gas.
Where are these deposit?
Who owns them?
How much is it worth
and how do we compensate
these nations and companies?
Although I think all this stuff
should be nationalized immediately.
There's no private company
that should be in charge of fossil fuels.
How do we compensate for
the loss of that money?
Because each country's burn can be tracked
back in time as well.
It can be tracked historically
right up and its present burn.
Both can be tracked.
And here's a rough cut.
If we can burn 500 out of 3,500,
possibly every country
should only be able to burn
one seventh of what they own
and then the rest they get paid
for keeping in the ground
in an amortized discounted
and over time way
because it would have
taken a couple of centuries
to burn all that.
And then in other words,
there is a financial aspect
to the good Anthropocene
that is crucial to think about.
I wanna come back to that before I end
but I see I have time for
just a couple more points.
Still thinking about
the good Anthropocene,
we need perhaps something like
E.O. Wilson's "Half-Earth."
A principle which sounded so
radical when he thought of it.
That 50% of the earth should
be left to the animals,
to the wild creatures
and we should keep our
activities to the other 50%
that's most useful to us.
This sounded like a very old
and distinguished scientist
going to Meredith
and suggesting something
completely utopian and crazy.
And then five years later,
European Union and other
nation state groups
are proposing 30% of the land
to be left to the animals.
It's amazing how quickly that came about.
And the Y2Y, Yukon-to-Yellowstone
habitat corridor,
is one indication that these wild zones
be connected up with each
other all over the earth.
If humans congregate more in cities
and then there's a carbon
draw down to re-wilding
as well as a dodging of
the mass extinction event,
which I claim is fundamental
to the whole project.
That leads to, of course, agriculture.
We gotta feed ourselves.
And it's interesting to contemplate
can agriculture become a carbon neutral
or even a carbon negative activity?
Growing of crops, ranching, aquaculture.
It said that an acre of
ocean water in the shallows
where kelp beds and sea grass can grow,
that that acre of a shallow ocean water
can hold five times more carbon
than an equivalent acre of land anywhere.
Indeed, carbon neutral agriculture
and food production in general
is gonna be on the table
as the technological work
of the good Anthropocene.
Very briefly,
I wanna mention geoengineering
but only because
the word has become reified,
by which I mean it's turned into a thing
and nobody discusses it.
And what it now really
means in popular parlance,
especially on the left where I live,
privileged white male elite
imposing a supposed silver
bullet techno solution
that will save their way of life
but probably backfire
and make things worse for everyone else.
That's geoengineering.
Well, define it that way
and indeed bad idea.
But if you think of
large scale interventions
in the biosphere
hoping to reduce the damage
of a global temperature rise
as being a definition.
Such that women's rights are
geoengineering for the good
or gardening is a
geoengineering for the good.
Anything we do at global scale
that has impacts because
there are so many humans
as small as they might be individually,
if they scale up,
you could think of that as geoengineering.
And then if you get to the famous case
of solar radiation management,
can we imitate Pinatubo and
throw dust into the atmosphere,
sulfur dioxide, whatever
to bounce some sunlight
off before it hits earth?
That would lower temperature
and it might only last five years
and the repercussions might
not be as significant.
I mean, who can tell?
But if we get desperate
in the 21st century,
there may be certain nation states
whose people are dying from heat waves
who may do this
and the rest of the world
having burned the carbon,
especially the developed
world in the North,
will have no moral standing
to objecting geoengineering
just for an idea.
So, it's an emergency.
It would be like pulling
the emergency alarm
and pulling out the fire extinguisher
in a good Anthropocene.
So, let me end by
going back to this matter of finance.
What is money?
Well, it's not as easy as you might think.
It's a medium of exchange.
It's a store place of value.
It's a demonstration of social trust.
So, if you're going to do the good work
of saving the biosphere and
creating a good Anthropocene,
you'd need to be able
to make a living at it.
And making a living is not
the same as making a profit
where you extract value
and hoard it to yourself
and become richer than everybody else.
There's really good
work on what finance is
and its relationship to the state
and the nation state system and finance,
which is to save money.
The world of finance are co-dependence
and they are interdependent.
People like Lazaretto say that
finance controls the state.
People like Joseph Vogel
and others say that
the two are hand in hand
but those two hands are
arm wrestling for control.
I think that's a good image for it.
But in any case,
when finances is in control of the state,
you get neo-liberal capitalism
and the bad point they're at now.
That doesn't work
and we've seen 40 years of it misfiring
despite various improvements
on other levels.
So, the good Anthropocene
will require state controlling finance.
And if the state is
of the people, by the
people, for the people
in some formulation
where you have good political
representation as a citizen
and your governments are
essentially your organizations
like a business but working for you
for the good of the planet,
then state controlling finance
is the natural and proper order
because it's people controlling
finance for the good.
So, what would that kind
of finance resemble?
Well, a job guarantee.
If the state guarantees you a job,
then unemployment as a problem goes away.
But also if that job
is a salary,
is compensated by an adequate life
so that you could get a job from the state
that gave you a living,
then all private industry
would have to match it.
So, job guarantee,
which is a fundamental
to modern monetary theory
is a good idea.
Progressive taxation
that actually creates a ratio of
if the people who are making
the most on the planet
were at adequacy,
that the least were at adequacy
and the people at the most
were making 10 times that,
a one to 10 ratio in wage
parody, it's sometimes called.
If you've got true adequacy,
then 10 times that is stupendous luxury.
But the world that we're in,
it's really a ratio of one
being grossly inadequate
and then the wealthiest
are like 500 times that
or 1,500 times that.
It's ludicrous
and it could be legislated
out of existence by taxation.
Then also paying off the oil companies
or the nations really
that own the fossil fuels
is part of it.
And how can we do that?
Well, money is created
by the Central Bank.
So, here I'm not talking about
speculative, bubble silliness
like Bitcoin, which is really just a scam.
I'm talking about fiat money
made by senior and by the powers that be.
States backed by armies
and by their people.
That's what real money is.
And if real money is made to pay first
for decarbonization work,
for a good Anthropocene work,
and it only gets paid out for that first,
that's a form of quantitative easing.
We know quantitative easing works.
Well, sort of works
but in other words,
it goes out there
and it doesn't completely
destabilize money as a concept.
In 2008,
they made up between five to $8 trillion
and poured it into the system
to keep the economy liquid.
With the pandemic in March,
they made up a couple
of trillion immediately
in order to keep people from starving.
So, carbon quantitative easing, CQE,
is an idea that's out there.
It's a great idea.
You sequester carbon,
you get a carbon coin.
It has to be defended
by the Central Banks.
It has to be made up by the
Central Banks in concept
so that it isn't just a crypto coin
or a speculative thing
that can be manipulated by finance.
It has to be solidly backed.
And then you're at something solid.
The civilization that pays
itself to do the right things.
And we're not there yet
but we have actually the mechanisms.
Globalization is not bad
because we're on one planet.
Bad globalization is bad
like the bad Anthropocene is bad.
Good globalization is in fact necessary
because it can't just
happen in one country.
There is no pocket utopia.
It's all or nothing,
which is frightening, of course.
But we're on one planet and
we have no choice in that.
So, I am going to end with that
and turn it back over to
Priya and the rest of you
and hope that we've survived our hack
and maybe that serves as a model.
All the good work that we do,
that is going to happen
in the face of chaos
and disruption and hacking
and people who don't
share the same ideology
and are gonna be trying to mess things up.
So, what I describe
is the lineaments of a
century long, wicked battle
and I'll end there.
- Thank you so much, Stan.
That was wonderful.
So, we'll open up for questions.
Ty, did you want to get started with...
- Yes, sure.
So, a comment and perhaps
leading to a question.
What would a good Anthropocene look like?
The problem is more
complex, somebody noted.
The sad fact is that
humans have not learned
to be themselves without
being anthropocentric.
So, this is what is fatal for the species,
the reason being simple.
No species cannot live
its life support system
and the person offering this common sense
will be no exception.
We cannot conceive of a world
in which we are not the center.
Your thoughts on that.
- Oh, sure.
Well, I think that's right.
The question is bringing up a valid point
that we need to be more biocentric.
We need to go back to the oldest religion,
a kind of Gaia religion,
where humans understand
that they are one node
in a larger network of living beings
and that they all are part of us.
I think the news that 50%
of the DNA inside your body
is not human DNA
is a shocking new fact
that has to change everybody
who contemplates it for awhile.
That you yourself or a forest or a swamp
are a biome of some kind
and everything has to work inside you
for you to stay healthy
and then you're part of a larger system
and everything has to work on that system
also to stay healthy.
So, at the micro and the macro,
we are interpenetrated with
the rest of the biosphere
and that can be a religious position
and it has been in the past
and it has to come back.
In terms of the question
of how it would look like,
let's say cities denser,
lots of more open land,
lots more respect for wild
animals as being our cousins,
our horizontal brothers and
sisters as John Muir once said,
and then go from there.
It would be a work in progress
and I would agree we're not there.
We're too anthropocentric
and it would be nice to
broaden our perspectives
to actually confront the reality
that we can't go it alone
as the person commented.
- [Ty] Okay.
- Yeah, and I think that
it might also be helpful
that every time we as humans
have thought that
we are at the center of the,
physical universe, right?
We've been displayed.
And hopefully now with the discovery
of all these other
exoplanets and possibilities,
even with just the nearby stars,
harboring other planets, right?
I think we need to get
sort of a little bit more humble
about cosmically where we are
and maybe this perspective will help us
become a little less anthropocentric.
But I see that
there is this tension
between our desire to always
be focused on ourselves.
But I think I really liked your point
that even what we think
is the boundary of us
is not really uniquely us.
We have bits of DNA from
others and very complex biome.
I was curious as we are waiting
to use my prerogative
as the organizer to ask you,
So, I understand the good Anthropocene
is really what we want to head toward
but we see a lot of practical,
mental, psychological,
aside from nation states
and that level of political disagreement
and ideological conflicts,
to say nothing of military conflicts.
At a personal, psychological,
emotional level,
do you have a way of thinking
about how we could all
effect that transformation
sort of to build towards that?
- That's a hard one
because different people are
in different circumstances
such that it's, I think,
dangerous or inappropriate
to give advice.
My situation as a suburban white man,
aging house husband in a suite
eco village in California.
This is an amazingly privileged position,
maybe one of the most privileged
in the history of the world
for a person, an individual.
So, I would say
take what I have to say
with a grain of salt
but one can drop one's
carbon burn dramatically
and we saw this with the pandemic
but you could do it voluntarily as well
and still have like more
fun than you were before.
Less crap in your life,
less worry and anxiety,
walking outdoors.
Just taking a simple walk
is actually more satisfying and restful
than almost any recreational
activity you can name,
especially the ones that
involve going somewhere else
and using mechanical means to get you,
I don't know.
I don't wanna put down
any particular activities
but you know what I mean.
- [Priya] Yeah.
And then if you grow plants,
even in pots in your apartment,
immediately, the first reaction is fear.
It's a stupendous technological
feat to keep ourselves fed.
It's not an automatic.
And so, growing plants of vegetables
or even ornamentals
is a huge lesson and a little
tiny bit of carbon draw down,
especially with the compost heap.
But also psychologically,
it reorients you to reality
because all of us I think are doing this
and I actually I appreciate very much
people coming to hear this talk
given everybody's Zoom and screen fatigue
and it means a lot to me
because I think that it's
a gesture towards GAO
and towards my novels
but all of us,
that needs to be integrated
with physical life
in the stuff that you can
touch with your hands.
And I think that that is a reorientation.
It's a kind of mapping activity
to go outdoors,
to sit in a garden,
to meet face-to-face as
socially distanced levels
for the next year or so.
But after that,
to realize that talking to
somebody over a cup of tea
is already the most pleasurable
activity that you have
and it's a rather low carbon burn.
- Thanks, a few more
questions have come up.
Are there no examples in history
from which we can learn
or should we really
look for a clean break?
- I think one has to be
able to learn from history.
Priya mentioned my novel "Shaman."
How are humans getting
by in the paleolithic?
And are there things
we can learn from them?
I think so,
even though I often talk
about the paleolithic
with good dental care.
In other words,
the things that we can
learn from the paleolithic
is not the totality of how to live.
That we are a technological
species and it's good.
And so, along the way,
medicine is one of the
fundamental technologies.
Public health is another one.
These systems that we have.
I think what one wants to do
is evaluate all earlier
historical societies
for what was valuable in them
even though they were partially enacted
and pull them out
and make them into a new thing.
So, I don't believe in a clean break.
I don't believe in a future humans
that would be radically distinct
from what we've been all along
but there certainly is some
distinctions to be made.
- Is it a Pandora's box
to pay nations and organizations
to not do something horrible to all of us?
Is paying them out really
the best practical solution
to keep oil in the ground.
- Maybe not.
Immediately, I think to myself,
that does sound bad
but I am thinking about the
way that we reward ourselves
for doing useful things by way of money.
And I'm thinking about what
they call climate equity,
which is written into the Paris agreement
that the people in the areas of the world
that are gonna suffer first
from climate change effects
are precisely the people
who have burned the
least amount of carbon.
So, the Paris agreement
is a stupendously strong
document on this front
because a certain cadre of
diplomats and philosophers
and hardworking activists
made the Paris agreement the way it is
by writing these things
in with huge arguments.
And what the Paris agreement says
is there's a schedule one
nation's developed world
that burned a lot of
carbon that are now rich.
There's a developing nation scheduled to
that are on the list as A and B
that owe less to the payouts necessary
because they've burned less carbon
and have suffered more in the results.
So, it wouldn't be just a case of
you go to Russia and say,
you've got 1,000 gigatons of carbon
and therefore we are going to give you
$20 trillion right now.
That wouldn't work.
That would crush the system.
You can pressure and use leverage
in the normal way of diplomacy
and of money in general,
to say,
look, we are going to compensate you,
but it's at a discounted rate
and you're gonna have
to do the right things.
You're gonna have to meet
carbon sequestration scheduling
in order to get the payout,
but then you do get paid for
doing the virtuous thing.
This is weirdly economic speak.
I believe that economics is too limited
of a way to talk about this
but we organize global society
by way of economic considerations.
And one part of economics
is a real and genuine social science
trying to find the best way forward.
The other part is just an excuse
for a power play of
the rich over the poor.
You gotta destrand economics
and get to the part that's useful to us.
- But isn't some of
this, what you suggest,
still within the framework
of transactional capitalism?
It's still very much that rubric, right?
So, I guess parts of
that we have to live with
because that's what we're built on.
Can't fundamentally shake
that apart in one go.
- Well, not in one go.
I like a stepwise march
to a true post-capitalism,
but given where we are now,
I would say anti-austerity, Keynesianism,
social democracies,
democratic socialism, post-capitalism
as a stepwise march
from one legal stage to the next
so that it's more orderly,
hopefully less violent
and more effective.
So, I, myself,
I'm a full-on post-capitalist.
I think capitalism is just
the name for a power system,
but we're in it.
And certainly money will still exist.
Certainly capital will still exist,
but what we pay ourselves to do
and how we own capital,
these are the big questions.
- As you know,
one American has the carbon footprint
equivalent to 20 Bangladeshi.
U.S. makes up 5% of the world's population
but using 25% of the world's energy.
What do you think of
Naomi Klein's perspective
on Anthropocene discourse
that the U.S. has a greater responsibility
in reducing the carbon footprint
than any other country on earth?
- I am in solidarity with Naomi Klein,
and I think she's right about that.
And then historically and accurately,
you have to immediately pull in
also China and the European
Union and soon enough India,
but these are at differential
rates historically.
So, climate equity,
climate justice
would require that the
United States leading the way
would make a huge difference.
You see small countries operating
with a stupendous care for their land
and with a very low carbon burn.
And this includes developed
countries like Switzerland
and developing countries like Cuba,
which often rates highest on human welfare
versus carbon burn rubrics.
So, Naomi Klein has done stupendous work
for clarifying these issues
to a general audience.
And I hope that her next
book is about the global,
about international finance
because although her
focus on local resistance
and on regional moves,
these are all necessary.
They're necessary but
they're not sufficient
because we're in this
international neo-liberal capital system
that will simply extract value
from the top of even good local work.
So, I think she knows this already
and I did an event with her
very recently at Rutgers.
And all I can is that
it would be great if her work
is as widespread as possible.
- Great, so Chao Carlos,
so we have a question from Carlo Rovelli.
He says everything that
you say is very reasonable,
and of course he likes and
falls in the same camp,
but he says
what I see missing is the political side.
In history,
rarely people have collaborated
just out of rational
thinking and common good.
Competition has always dominated
unless imposed by a power.
How do we move politically
towards collaboration?
And we had a very similar
question along the same lines
from John Peters who said,
recently our country voted for a candidate
who openly opposed this kind of thinking.
So, how do you handle political roadblocks
to the good Anthropocene?
- Well, for me, there are two levels here.
One is the discursive battle.
In other words,
it's like this.
It's talking about it.
It's convincing enough people,
persuading people
that your ideological explanation
for what's going on in the world
is correct enough to act upon.
So, the discursive battle
is very, very important.
And then I have to say,
you're only ever gonna get
a working majority at best.
So, you have to give up on
the notion of a consensus
or have a huge majority.
Despite the obvious utility
of saving the biosphere,
a lot of people don't see it that way.
And with the most vigorous,
discursive, persuasive battle,
they're still not gonna see it that way
because people love their views
and none of us likes to change our views.
So, a working majority is 51%
like in the general election,
but then there's the electoral college.
A working majority is sometimes up to 60%
before you can actually work,
like in certain votes in
the U.S. Senate at 60%.
A high bar in the current divisive world,
I have to say fossil fuel
extractive industries
are pouring immense amounts of money
into disinformation campaigns
and into buying the votes of legislators
who are elected on one platform
and then vote on another
and support the continued carbon burn.
Well, this one has to become unacceptable
and that's partly the discursive battle
and partly political organizing
and partly fighting for different laws.
So, the working majority
can change the laws
and then the laws can change
the structure of feeling
and the economic system together at once.
So, I don't have any good answers for this
because no one does.
I mean, it's politics, right?
It's ugly, it's irrational.
It has to do with a very tribal sensations
of us versus them.
And it's nice to try to
pull away from that and say,
but wait, everybody's on the same planet
and everybody loves their children.
And there you get back
to the discursive battle.
Well, that being the case,
can you persuade people
that decarbonization
and a new way of living with the biosphere
is just in everybody's best interest.
I think you can tell from what I'm saying,
that this is a way of saying that
there's nothing but continued struggle.
- I have centric communities
are all small communities.
Maybe one solution is to
have small local communities.
And I wonder whether COVID
has given us glimmers
of what that might look and feel like,
one participant suggests.
- Well, I wonder about that.
And I think it's a human fact
that we like our community.
My teacher, Gary Snyder once talked about
community versus network.
So, your community or
the people that you see
and talk to and interact with.
And of course, in, in the COVID regime,
this is very weird.
Our communities have been damaged.
Your network is everybody
that you're connected with
all over the world, by
this medium and others.
So, at the community level,
you can organize your town.
You can actually make an impact
at the level of your town
to do better around climate.
American towns are trying their best
to confront this crisis by
cutting their carbon burn
at the town level.
That is absolutely great.
And something that we need to focus on.
And not only that,
but when you focus on that,
you can see results of your work.
You can talk to people
it's social activity
with some results.
The international situation is so...
I mean, you're 18 billion
of the power structure of the planet,
but a lot of people have more money
and therefore more power than you do.
That's so abstract that it ends up
at the level of discourse.
So, I would say essentially
that you needed it all.
And that I ended up
talking about the global
and partly because,
well, Naomi Klein and others are great
at talking about the regional,
and then everybody is involved
with their own local efforts.
And, I would say that these are all great,
but that they aren't sufficient
to complete the deal,
which is to change the rules
of international capitalism itself
at the level of treaties,
at the level of central
banks at the level of money.
I bring that into the discourse,
not because I think it's the silver bullet
or the total solution,
but because I think it is a necessary part
of all the rest of the efforts.
It has to be integrated from...
And it isn't even good
to say bottom to top.
It has to be integrated
from a local to planetary,
let's put it that way.
- So Tim asks, what can be
the role for higher education
in the face of the
kinds of transformations
that you were calling for?
- Well, I am interested.
I'm an ex academic,
and I'm always involved with
universities like Yale here.
I do a lot.
And I'm thinking, talking to young people,
they are actually more
flexible in their ideologies
and they're learning to
shape their ideologies
and where they're gonna serve
their efforts in a career.
I think there ought to be a freshmen class
that I see very clearly in my mind.
I mean, I'm talking about the
syllabus and the readings,
and that would in their
first year of college,
give them a cognitive mapping.
Like I just tried here, an
orientation to the world.
This is the world situation.
There's a science fiction element to that,
that I've been incorporating.
I talked to students who are,
let's say they're 20 years old.
Let's say I'm very close to 70 years old,
a half century gap.
I tell them when you're my age,
it will be the year 2070.
You will be in a
completely different world
by necessity because of the
way things are going now
cannot be sustained.
It will change in their lifetimes.
So, higher education ought to be seized,
the professorial class
and the administrations.
And these are actually groups
that are at odds with each other.
Often the academic sentence, let's say,
since they're still in
control of pedagogy,
to a certain extent,
they ought to be looking at
this situation and saying,
we need to orient these young people,
and send them out into the world
with a well-organized cognitive map
for figuring out what they're
gonna do with their lives
without getting scared,
without freaking out,
without sending them off into
various kinds of doomerism.
Like, okay,
the world is so doomed that
I'm just gonna go party.
Well, most young college students
are not going to college in
order to take that attitude.
So, they're well set for an education
that would teach them these things
and get them oriented to
the rest of their lives.
- So then we have a question
that touches a little bit
on the personnel, in which full-on us,
they're interested in,
whether the experience of
having worked as a house husband
has informed your perspective.
Do you think a transfer
of more power to women
may radically change our ability
towards the good Anthropocene?
- Oh, yes.
Definitely so.
And I want to thank
the questioner for that
because it's important when women have
their full set of legal rights,
and I'm not talking about
reproductive rights,
I'm talking about property,
education and general,
the rights that they are guaranteed
by the UN declaration of human rights.
The reproduction rate goes down
to below the replacement rate.
So, replacement rate is
2.1 or 2.2 kids per woman
in developed countries where
women have their rights
and are busy with their lives.
It goes down to about
1.5 to 1.8 per woman.
And the population begins to drop
and the pressure on the
biosphere goes away.
And then also, this
brings up all of the work
that mostly women do that
keeps alive the world
that then capitalism can be a
parasite on and make profit.
There is no profit without
social reproduction,
and that's a word for
uncompensated labor of care.
So, taking care of the little kids,
educating the littlest kids and
nursing and taking care of the elderly,
a lot of this is outside of the economy.
And if it were included in the economy,
profits would be wiped out.
So, that's on one of the ways
in which profit is a scam,
but also you don't want to
economize care and love.
So, you can't just say,
"Okay, I took care of my grandmother,
"pay me $20 for that hour."
No, what you would need
is a political economy
that created the space
that people could have
an adequate living
and still do the human work
of social reproduction.
Well, most of the world
women's simply have taken on the burden
of doing both of these things at once.
And this is why there's so
much pressure on women's lives,
is they've got a double job.
One, to make money in the
economy and do their work.
B, to take care of their
families, both older and younger,
and maybe even partners.
And this is simply like 20 hours a day.
So yeah, it is super important
to support the women in the world,
to be a feminist.
Men need to say, "Oh yeah, I'm a feminist,
"but only in a follower's kind of a way,
"not a leaders kind of way."
And also see that the laws have changed
and that the rest of the world,
I mean, if the United States is the leader
and it's not quite true,
you're scanning Navy as
a leader in these issues.
And there are many places in the world
beginning to emphasize women's rights.
Then they have to work hard
to pull the rest of the world
along in that.
And that will really help biosphere health
and human welfare, yes.
And by the way, thank you for that.
Because that really ought
to be an element of my talk
and it often is.
- So, in the red moon,
you mentioned the concept
of blockchain democracy.
Do you want to discuss that
in the context of the future Anthropocene?
Does it have a room for that?
- Well, I think so.
Let me confess that blockchain
is difficult to understand technology
and it often gets confused with Bitcoin,
which I quite hate,
but blockchain as a system of encryption
that is distributed and
solidified our information
about things so that there,
it creates a more transparent world,
as well as a more secure
world of digital information.
I can imagine money being blockchain,
such that you can't have tax havens
or hidden criminal money.
I can imagine democracy
being in blockchain,
and this is true at town
levels in the United States.
It's open government.
It's illegal to meet in private.
And then blockchain would
kind of digitalize that.
I'm a little confused as to
the utility of blockchain.
Sometimes people tell me,
well, it's just a buzzword for codes
that are actually simpler
that are completely available to us.
So, why even use that word?
And you don't want the
repetitiousness of Bitcoin's creation
of value by way of running
computers for zillions of hours
to no purpose.
It's something like 2%
of the world's energy
is being burned in order to make Bitcoin.
Well, this is just
carbon burn foolishness,
is something like the
economy of a Czech Republic
or even Israel being burned
for nothing except for a scam.
So, I'm not so sure about blockchain.
I would need the digital
experts to weigh in on that.
- So there's a comment from Yanni Joseph.
How about the need to
drastically cut military budgets?
- Well, that would be
fantastic, especially.
Yeah, the U.S military budget is bigger
than all the rest of the
military budgets combined.
And the U.S has 800 military
bases placed around the world
and is a functioning low
key to functioning empire.
And that doesn't work.
What I can say about the military is
I'm looking at the Swiss
military in particular,
but also all those militaries
that end up being kind of
an emergency rescue services.
And in the United States, the U.S Navy,
I mean the U.S military burns
a stupendous amount of carbon uselessly,
but they're also aware that
decarbonization is a
national security issue.
And the Navy has run a nuclear
fleet without accidents
because they don't try
to make a profit from it.
And safety comes first.
They also have been involved
in rescue operations,
and it's also true that in modern warfare,
navies are all sunk to the bottom
in the first week of a war.
And so, they need to be
thinking about rescue
and non-military confrontation.
And in short,
if the world got together
on this carbon coin,
if civilization was devoted
to trying to avoid the
mass extinction event,
then the militaries would end up being
like the CCC ONE hopes,
a place of service and not have conflict.
And then their budgets of
course could go way down
on the extremely expensive armaments race.
This could be brought to
an end by mutual agreement.
And should be part of the big deal.
- So, let's close with the final question,
which is about a word.
So, I thought this might be a nice way.
So a vibrant biosphere
and adequacy for all,
along with the global security
which would go with that,
would be a very charismatic goal.
Could we have come up with a
better term than just adequacy?
Would this (mumbles) be the border
of a powerful political movement?
(laughs)
- Yeah, adequate is not
is not exactly exciting.
Well, okay, here's something
that I want you to contemplate.
It's an old English saying
in Bartletts quotations,
it comes on like page seven or something,
and it's anonymous.
Enough is as good as a feast.
Now, it was hungry people
that brought up that,
that made up that proverb
and they knew what they were talking about
because there were
feasts from time to time
when the harvests were good,
but enough is as good as a feast.
The more you think about
that, the deeper it goes.
So, okay.
Enough is sort of a word like adequate,
but you need the whole phrase,
enough is as good as a feast
and indeed a feast being bad for you.
You could change the old proverb and say
enough is better than a feast.
So, the word very often has been utopia.
The word has been utopia.
Now, the same way
ideology is what the
other person believes,
utopia is the good place
that we never get to,
that is impossible.
So, definitions matter.
But I have been working
in the utopian tradition
my whole career with the idea that
a better world is possible,
and you need to describe it
first in order to get to it.
So, I'm constantly
defending the term utopian,
but that because of the attacks on it,
which are political attacks,
what would you say?
Maybe prosperity,
because enough is a form of
prosperity and or justice,
maybe justices the word.
So these, I think are much
more inspiring than adequacy.
And I thank the questioner
for pointing that out,
and it is a word game because
it's the discursive battle.
So, let's think about justice and utopia.
- Yeah, that's great.
Actually, there's one burning question
that I think is so important
that I'm really tempted
if you don't mind.
So, there is a view
sometimes held by indigenous
and post-colonial discourse
that the entire discourse
of the Anthropocene
is of sort of white panic.
Privileged white people who
for the first time realized
that their ascendancy in
life is being threatened.
It echoes a bit of what you said
about the stereotype of geoengineering.
Can you respond to that?
- Well, I can see that.
What I would say is that the Anthropocene
is a word thought up by
scientist to wave the red flag,
to pull the emergency alarm
on the wall in the hotel
and go off like a fire
alarm and shock everybody.
We're in an era where human beings
have a over determining
effect on the biosphere
that can be destructive.
And so, we're in the business of
global planetary biospheric management
or finessing or cooperation.
Management sounds bad, but cooperation.
I mean, we need to get along
in our biosphere for the long haul.
So, there's been so much argument
about what the Anthropocene means
that I think that this
also can be included.
Some people date the Anthropocene
to simply the arrival
of humans out of Africa.
People got to Australia
and by the use of fire,
they changed the biosphere,
the biomes of Australia by fire
within a thousand years of arrival.
In other words, the whole
history of humanity,
including indigenous people
has been involved with
cooperating with the
natural productive forces
of the planet, the growth,
such that the Amazon for instance,
was a gigantic park with islands of
heavily nitrogenated highland gardens.
In other words,
the native population of the Amazon basin
was in good cooperative relations
with that very vibrant and
quickly growing landscape,
difficult landscape for humans.
And yet humans had it in hand
and were living with it cooperatively
for thousands of years.
So, the indigenous ought
to always be remembered
and they are not distinct
from the Anthropocene.
And there's good reasons for white panic.
I mean, white people
are actually a minority
in the world's population,
and they had a moment of
triumphalism and of white supremacy
and all of the worst kind of ways.
And that's gonna go away demographically
and politically and spiritually,
but you know what, to get back.
I mean, as an aging white man,
I can just say it's more comfortable
just to be one of the group
than to be anything special.
- I guess, in a cosmic sense, right?
We are all simultaneously
significant and insignificant.
Anyway, Stan,
thank you so much for this wonderful talk
and for taking the time
to answer these questions.
We were absolutely
delighted to have you speak
at the Franke program today.
- Thank you.
My pleasure.
And I wanna say,
I will have the chats forwarded to me
so that I can actually see
what people have been saying.
I haven't been looking in order to focus
on what we're talking,
but I'm interested to
read what people said,
and I want to thank you Priya
for the idea of having me
and for everybody else involved.
It's a great pleasure.
- Thank you very much.
And thanks everyone for joining in
and making this a vibrant event.
Bye, and see you all later.